[Musica]
einstein
lui arriva vi scordate che ho fatto il
video in cui avrei comprato tutto quello
che berlino voleva quindi tutto quello
che il mio cagnolino vuole ecco ho una
notizia per voi
berlino ha distrutto tutto
chi è il colpevole vi metto quale foto
di tutte le cose che ha distrutto al
davvero distrutto tutti i giochi ha
distrutto tutti i tappetini ha distrutto
tutti i lettori
e ora il problema è che non sa più con
cosa giocare visto che tutti i suoi
giochi sono distrutti e prende le mie
cose da distruggere in d ora lui sta
cercando un nuovo e questa distruzione
ovviamente io non voglio che distrugga
le mie cose
ogni mattina mi sveglio e nel suo
lettino a una calza dei caso geri una
maglietta via prende di nascosto
ovviamente mentre sto dormendo questo
siccome ha distrutto tutto e ha bisogno
di qualcos'altro con cui giocare
altrimenti distruggere tutte le mie cose
andremo nuovamente a negozi di animali
qualsiasi cosa lui tocca la compreremo
così berlino avrà dei mid cap lo stesso
video raggiunto i 10 mila mi piace anche
se non sbaglio ne ha 13 mila grazie
mille avevo detto che se avesse
raggiunto i 10 mila mi piace avrei fatto
una seconda parte quindi se anche questo
video raggiunge il 10 mila mi piace fare
una terza parte
sei proprio viziato merlino
il resto tutto berlino non sa cosa sta
per succedere o pensando non mi dire che
mi portano dal veterinario nuovamente
una volta l'abbiamo portato dal
veterinario non so come ha capito che
dovevamo andare dal veterinario e 6
nascosto dentro un armadio è
intelligentissima cocchiere questo che
il miur e furba che ho ricordato questa
crescita loro marino è un pò stanco e se
vuole dormire però una volta che saremo
al negozio di animali sono sicura che si
ravviverà tutto sarà felicissimo devo
lavorare tutto è scegliere tutti i suoi
giochini non ci sarà ammesso un budget
per questa challenge quindi qualsiasi
cosa sceglie io dovrò comprare vado il
mio cagnolino volta che guardo in faccia
allora siete pronti prendete le patatine
i pop corn e andiamo subito al negozio
di animali
eccoci qua siamo in macchina e stiamo
andando a negozi pieni pali berlino mi
sento facciamo più vendiamo gli animali
signora bella museruola ha toccato una
pallina ci vado ma l'attaccate ma
dobbiamo prendere più che altro per
questi tipi di
[Applauso]
vediamo non è proprio il tenore detto
che se no è in guerra petti giochi di
quello tattico kg berlina quale voi
questo mi piace a berlino per appetite
buchi con il boom no un'altra palla ma
l'avevo già presa ti piace noi diamo qui
conservo che cos'è e cosa si voleva
giorgia che va bene prendiamo
l'elefantino lui cosa ha toccato che
cos'è ma x pappagalli che così un
ghiacciolo per cani
[Musica]
proviamo poi merlino tutto aiutare
grazie sono anche le poc
[Musica]
esatto
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no per effetti pupazzi a lui perché lui
allora non siamo in tre giorni
questo coniglietto e questa me la
vediamo berlino malevoli
ehi
lamela voi andiamo lamela scherzi questo
giro
mary visto quante cose concrete che
interessano queste
berlino durante felice fate voi le
forchette con quante belle coperto e
berlino dei distruggerebbe tutte le
morbide per sé troppo piccola per
berlino aspetto appoggia la testa di
parate che carino che sono corda dentro
anche vediamo col estendiamo quale si è
fare lui mi sa che vuole questo nota
[Musica]
aspetta aspetta non lo puoi distruggere
ancora prima la dobbiamo pagare
ok siamo in macchina stavo tornando
abbiamo comprato un sacco di cose ora
torniamo vi facciamo vedere cosa abbiamo
comprato anche cosa assetto berlino e
quando abbiamo comprò ma siamo tornati a
casa solo di un berlinetta e ora vi
facciamo vedere tutte le cose che se il
tuo berlino allora iniziamo con il primo
giochino allora ha scelto un una sorta
di elefante un po deforme però vabbè è
un elefante arancione che fa rumore
questo che stava 9 euro e 25 gol che
foto di da è questo da 1 a 10
quale reagisce meglio merlino per fare
più contento per questo mi sembra che
sia un aspetto che non merita un 7 7 e
mezzo è contento ma non troppo diciamolo
era poi alla fine metterò tutto tutti i
giochi di sul tavolo e veniamo quale se
gli berlino così sappiamo fare se
preferì abbiamo questo giochino è un po
strano perché sa qualcosa qua dietro
forse serve per mettere il cibo tempo il
forum ore anche lo stesso momento può
essere questo 11 e 90 ma era scontato
vediamo
un trend luglio ma il voto dai a questo
giochino berlino ma perché sarei fatto
comprare non mi sembra molto convinto da
questo gioco nuovo buttato
ecco come voglio tutto l'etichetta così
forse gli piace un po di più una specie
di scoiattolo con qualcosa nel sederino
ti piazzi per dire ecco allora merlino
si è voluto spostare preferisci il letto
al tavolo touch e rosicchiando questo
quindi questo forse gli piacerà perché
ti piace a rosicchiare merlino quindi
speriamo che rosicky questi giocattoli
non leggo i korn e ora tutto quindi
direi che a questo gioco di da un 8 che
sia la trafila dispiaciuto se lo stato e
rosicchiato tutto prossimo giochino
abbiamo una linea che la prima che ha
scelto togliamo l'etichetta proviamo a
tirargli le vediamo se la rincorre da
d'amico ed io il mio
dai diritti alla pallina di down
roger mezzo busto ancora all'inizio di
piace tanto però dopo un po si sa quando
può poco tempo fa vi abbiamo già uno
però ed in plastica dura e non riesce
bene a rosie chiaro questo è di plastica
molle quindi penso che riuscirà meglio a
rossi chiaro vediamo merlina per mero
dottoressa tina latina forse abbiamo
dentro casa sul pavimento po più
difficile fuori fuori sofferma invece se
la paranza sicuramente
io gioco gli diamo un nome quando lo
prende infatti comincia sempre a tirare
o meno questo ti piace proprio come
adesso ce l'ha fatta a prenderlo ma che
cos'è questo è un ghiacciolo che cos'è
allora questo è un ghiacciolo per cani
ebbene sì non so come funzioni vediamo
sicuramente si può riempire e dentro
aspetta proviamo ad aprirlo resta ad
aprirla allora un buon profumo
però io penso che si aprisse si
riempisse si potesse mettere quello che
vogliamo insomma per fare proprio chi è
solo per cani in realtà si apre solo da
qua
ecco qua si apre il tappino si mette
l'acqua si mette in freezer diventa
bello fresco e poi il nostro cagnolino
in questo caso berlino si può giocare
con un giochino molto più fresco così lo
rinfresca un po perfetto per le storie
di vedere andiamo a riempirlo che ti
dopo glielo diamo prese allora tra tutti
i giochi che abbiamo visto finora
merlino si è fissato con il breve quindi
vista che finora è il suo preferito
berlino che non riesci più staccati lo
adora
ma vediamo se ora statista come degli
altri abbiamo un gioco un po complicato
tra l'altro questo la giovane
contava più di tutti costava 19 50
quindi praticamente 20 euro ticket e
vediamo come funziona questo gioco è una
media con il bambino che carina qua la
mela da quanto capito se il vino è
lunghissimo ho paura che marino
distruggere questo qui sia lamela che il
bambino allora ripetiamo glielo dentro
vediamo se riesce a tirar fuori da casa
ma non te ne frega niente
e quello che passava di pieno verbena
davide che di teresa proviamo
metterglielo per terra invitiamo il vino
pleiadi sfizio kg nuovo bar megawatt
avanzano questo giochino pochi giorni
nostri
aspetto vediamo se riesce a togliere il
blocchetto siamo solo col trattato da
merlino servizio vedere il bruco berlino
vinitaly il trucchetto no ma mai come va
il mio guarda quello che ne un dominio
però sembra che vi piaccia bilancio
partirà da tra la salva sopra
assassino
ci siamo quasi
dai quarti tolta e adesso si è distratto
con l'altro giorno ma a quanto pare
berlino non ha interessato tanto alla
mela col gruppo ha preferito un buco
tenerla lì sotto la sua zampetta e lione
china la bocca e nella ripresa il
secondo il giochino quello tutto vero
berlino io prendo la mela berlino guarda
il trucchetto da allora ho usato il
progetto come sharp ah ah ah ma allora
adesso ci giochi dai titoli e monaco
ma ecco onore questo brugo va il rumore
[Musica]
marino i suoi giochi bene sono contenta
che si sta divertendo anche con il gioco
più costoso di tutti perché secondo me
adesso abbiamo troppi giochi quindi non
sapevo tutto le scelte allora un'altra
cosa che abbiamo preso è un'altra
ciotola per l'acqua perché lui sa già
dove c'è solo è una precisa una per
l'acqua per oggi ne vogliamo mettere
un'altra per l'acqua anche un'altra area
fuori perché a volte si dimentica di
bene perché non ha voglia di scendere le
scale emanuele quindi mettiamo un'altra
struttura per l'acqua e blu come sono
chiti e alle zampette e l'osso
disdegnati quindi questa non penso che
gli interesserà molto soprattutto 6
volta dentro in quanto si sta divertendo
i puristi nuovi giochi
ora passiamo all'ultimo gioco vediamo se
sarà quello che si sa se più di tutti
[Musica]
intanto il bruco solo sta mangiando
ancora l'ultimo zucchino d'oro in
pratica in questo giochino non però c'è
il disegno che dentro c'è una corta
vedete
guardate un po sei un accordo dentro
quindi da quanto ho capito berlino deve
riuscire a liberarlo perché c'è scritto
primi che vuol dire liberami non so come
però non so se deve proprio distruggerlo
lì che non sarà un problema serio lo
distruggerà subito oppure se c'è tipo
una tasca per togliere questa corda ma
ora vediamo quanto gli piace amberley ok
eccolo qua non vedo nessun buco per
togliere la corda quindi forse merlino
dovrà veramente distruggerlo vediamo
berlino berlino
penso che questa piazza secondo me non
era pochissimo questo fu padre ha molto
poco in bocca berlino e commenti secondo
quel quanto durerà questo pupazzetto
quanti giochi che ci averli netto del
riuscirà a liberare in un cassetto e
tirare fuori la corda proviamo a
controllare tra 15 minuti in realtà già
distrutto
poi l'ultima cosa siccome abbiamo speso
un bel po ci hanno regalato questo
contenitore
vediamo un po come fatto per mettere
dentro tipo le cose del pic nic
noi lo utilizzeremo per mettere dentro
tutte le cose di merlino quindi magari
come mettiamo tutti i giochi
la bottiglia d'acqua quando si può
mettere qualche crocchetta qualche visto
finora dobbiamo mettere tutti i giochi
per terra e vediamo qual è il suo
preferito
ok invitato il sito con berlino ecco qua
tutti i giochini posizionati vediamo
quello che prenderà per primo quindi
sapremo qual è il suo preferito pronti a
entrare pure via il piano il problema
nola già mollato ma la palla e fa batte
gigi merlino quale seggi la pallina
come potete vedere è felicissimo diverso
massimo bizzocchi ma secondo me perché
gli piacciono tutti prevediamo con quale
per rimane a giocare così sapremo quale
su preferito mi sa che quello è il suo
preferito collo rosa sì mi sembra
proprio che comunque la schiaccia a
causa di più
merlino quale seggi con la dei segni di
berlino scelto quello rosa che una sorta
di beni cotter o parla anche la palla ma
anche tanto presto la palla quindi ma
questi sono i due preferiti spero
comunque che giocherà anche con gli
altri
scrivete nei commenti secondo voi quanto
te le future hanno questi giorni vediamo
quanto tempo li distruggerà ok fammi
sapere secondo voi a fare il giochino
più bello secondo me il più carino e
vediamo se lo prende berlino berlino qui
è un po è troppo distratto perché
supercontento gioiellino è arrivata la
mela quindi mi raccomando lasciato un
bel mi piace se volete vedere una terza
parte ora vi lascio fa 4 caselline a
purificare per vedere i nostri altri
video le case sopra l'hanno preferito e
buona visione
[Musica]